what's happening there reject nation greg and
john here today we're gonna watch the official
trailer for the boys season three which we will be
covering on this channel a lot coming out in june
so we're gonna need some additional
help with editors so with that in mind
enjoy today's video sponsor thank you to
athletic greens for partnering up with us
this month well the schedule is wild as ours it's
tough to stay on top of proper diet and nutrition
luckily athletic greens eg1 formula makes your
daily nutrition simple delicious inconvenient get
bigger just one scoop contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals probiotics and a whole bunch
more which supports gut health nervous and immune
systems energy focus plus on a serious note ag-1
is lifestyle friendly i'm actually allergic
to dairy so any shake i ever have has to be
dairy-free so whether you eat keto paleo vegan
dairy-free or gluten-free it's a good fit plus
it's completely natural no harmful chemicals or
gmos and for my sake it helps improve my sleep
quality and mental clarity which is always a
boost it helps improve my gut health i like to
poop and i like saving money and what's great
about athletic greens is your subscription only
costs about three dollars a day that's double
what i paid john and it comes with a year supply
of vitamin d and all that is way cheaper than
trying to get all these supplements individually
so head on over to athleticgreens.com
rejects to start your ag-1 lifestyle today
so let me say it again cam i may be a superhero
but i'm also just a man who fell in love with the
wrong woman he's the man who fell for the wrong
woman uh for the wrong woman she was a great nazi
i am very excited for everyone to meet
the real men there's something wrong
we've been on the straight and narrow all year
i'm killing soups no drinking even follow
hugh campbell's orders without strangling him
no you're just being crazy or
maybe you're not such an [__]
people are super dumbs just to be with this family
but real power isn't this it's the ability
to bend the girl to your will oh yeah oh no
oh god we can fight about the right way but we
can't it's all rigged we have to do it your way oh
we're all we've got it's up to us i
think i have something what you got
[__] brains out
doing falcon winter soldier problems yeah for
24 hours you're gonna need it nice yeah here
we go boys go point what we do is that
no one should have that kind of power
for once i level the [__] playing field
i show people crimson counters
the deep getting back at the seven [__] [__]
oh god i love it i love it wait love it wow
there's a lot to unpack in that trailer amazon
primed ready for this bad boy this is this awesome
adventure i love kicking it off with homelander
though after everything you experienced with
stormfront you know it's like you've seen him
constantly searching for validation and
approval in the most psychotic of ways
and now he's really finding it even more so it
was already leaning this direction but now it's
more apparent than ever it's it's going to
be with like the more the alt-right camp
which seems suiting seems apt knowing what eric
kripke likes to talk about and knowing the type
of character homelander is voice has always
been political go back to the season one it's
always been a political show if you don't like
it sorry to break it to you i'm excited to see
just how much more crazy he is because this has
been like a slow escalation to him just having
the ultimate breakdown and this feels like every
season he's just gonna get more and more unleashed
as it progresses i'm excited for it man what do
you think about our boy soldier boy boy i cannot
wait at all to see what jensen brings to
the season and and seeing even these brief
glimpses here it seems like he's going to be
pretty important it seems like from at least
the brief synopsis of the season part of it is
going to be about them trying to find interact
with him one of the first supes you know i just
loved the you know the character that we even
are able to glean out of this trailer like he does
look like somebody who is a more hardened kind of
steve rogers type and i like that imagery of like
him stepping out of the what looks like the super
soldier serum uh you know chamber and whatnot
and uh what looks like some incredibly huge
level of power it's like you see him at first with
the shield yeah going all uh us agent on some guy
and then you see him later on with that big like
fire explosion which i can't imagine would be his
death scene i'm pretty sure that's his emergency
yeah exactly so uh i cannot wait to see what he
brings to this because he's got the chops for the
drama but you also know that he's going to be off
the leash having fun we know what he can be like
as a gruff you know authoritative figure but i'm
also excited to see what kind of satirical and
wild uh traits they might bring to him in this
arena where they don't have as many restrictions
as like on the cw it's funny in the in the comics
he's a little bit more pathetic but he's kind
of more akin a guy who who really looks to be
accepted and it seems like that's not going to be
the portrayal here he's going to be more of the
serious intimidating type of character i'm
really looking forward to seeing what his scenes
are going to be with anthony starr specifically
because watching those two pair it up is going
to be awesome yeah we're seeing our boys getting
a chance to use some compound v for a change you
know like they've teased a lot of what butcher's
abilities are going to be like some super strength
the lasers will frenchy and uh mother's milk what
will their powers and abilities be and i like that
maeve is actually getting more involved in the
battle as well we're going to be seeing this
other team who's more of a spoof of like the way
how seven is more of a spoof of justice league
we're getting the team payback which is more of
a spoof of the avengers so in the trailer you
saw the character who kind of looks like scarlet
witch crimson countess i i'm curious to see what
kind of commentary they'll have on it because
dc's been able to at least do a couple of r-rated
properties so far the boys comics would often do
meta commentary about comic books boys show has
taken the opportunity to do meta commentary about
comic book movies now they can take a stab at like
the marvel films where they can go all out that
one scene is i think is going to make a lot of
people be reminded of falcon and winter soldier
which was considered like one of the most brutal
moments in the marvel tv show pantheon but here
you know that they're gonna go all out and we did
get some teases a little bit of congressman newman
which was how the season left off with revealing
that she was the one exploding everyone's heads
we still don't know what her ultimate agenda is
they're still keeping her mysterious i was under
the impression that maybe they'd be leading more
with her considering she was the cliffhanger of
season two however i can't tell if she's gonna end
up working with the boys again if her ultimate
agenda is to take down the evil supes as well
i don't know man it seems like they're probably
gearing up for some kind of level of satire with
her too because he says that thing about like i
tried to do it the legit way and it's just not
possible i mean you got like some great little
teases throughout with this trailer obviously
homelander being so heartbroken by stormfront
there's this one scene where it looks like he's
intimidating a train considering that a train
is the one who gave all the information about
stormfront's nazi background to huey and starlight
i imagine that homelanders going to find out what
a train actually did and maybe that's what that
scene is implying when he's threatening him you do
see glimpses of the boy ryan son of a homelander
i didn't know for sure if he'd be back or not but
they've teased him a couple times now he's going
to be getting into the mix what the vibe i'm sort
of getting from what the boys season three is
going to be dealing with is everyone reaching
like breaking point freaking the boys have decided
to use compound b the thing they've hit they well
some version of compound b or something of that
nature it's only 24 hours project power yeah
that's what it is yeah some version of that that
allows them to have some powers which is something
that you know in the previous seasons you would
assume they'd be opposed to doing anything of that
nature the deep after everything he's gone through
looks like he might even be getting back into the
seven in some way based or at least that's his
goal that he's constantly striving for even with
soldier boy after awakening in modern day time his
mind has broken everyone seems like they're on the
verge of breaking point not sure exactly what
they're doing with like giancarlo esposito and
starlight if they're trying to tease a direction
that starlight might be going down some dark path
i imagine it's just another form of her doing
further infiltration into uncovering stuff so
they can finally take down bot i think this is
gonna be an awesome possum season i am super
duper stoked for it so be sure to look out
for when our reactions for this show come
up guys if you can subscribe please do that get
accepted into the reject nation also let's do a p
michael bear michael my boy michael boyd
michael is uh has his own channel omni media
constantly like to shout it out because he is one
of the best out there currently doing reactions
and reviews wonderful commentary you bet your
ass is going to be covering the boys as well so
if you like reaction channels and you want to get
acquainted with another one that's freaking great
and certainly deserves more subscribers than
us go subscribe to omni media today because he
is awesome at everything he does ladies
and gentlemen we'll catch you guys soon